if you spend enough time on YouTube I'm
sure you've heard of better help they're
the online therapy platform that's
supposed to help people work through the
darkest portions of their lives and for
the most part they do a pretty good job
they have managed to grow a massive
network of 23 000 fully certified
experienced therapists who serve over
two and a half million people and it
seems that almost all of these users are
pretty happy given that they have over a
hundred thousand reviews on the App
Store with an average rating of 4.8 but
it's not all good news you see what
better helps overall goals and
intentions may be pure their behavior
has largely been influenced by the need
to maximize profits and Achieve global
domination as the go-to mental therapy
platform for example you've probably
heard of doctor patient privilege this
is one of the most important aspects of
therapy more times than not people visit
therapists to open about topics that
they're ashamed about or embarrassed
about Dr patient privilege is what
encourages these people to share their
vulnerabilities and get the help they
need as such protecting doctor patient
privilege is of utmost importance for
most clinics and therapists but this
doesn't seem to be the case I'd better
help in fact better help has repeatedly
sold sensitive data to Facebook Snapchat
Pinterest and other such platforms over
the past several years but that's not
even the worst part the worst part is
how they address the situation when the
FTC confronted them about this practice
earlier this year the normal response
would have been to either deny that they
were selling this data or to issue a
public apology for their behavior but
betterhelp actually had the audacity to
claim that yes they were selling data
but no it's not wrong they would write
off the situation as quote industry
standard of practice routinely used by
some of the largest Health Providers
Health Systems and Healthcare Brands it
seems that better hope has made their
position clearer and that's just the tip
of the iceberg so join me as we take a
look at the dark side of a better help
[Music]
usually when we're talking about data
privacy it's more of an ethical question
as opposed to a legal one for example
Google and metastata collection it is
questionable from an ethical perspective
but not from a legal one after all they
lay out exactly what they're going to
collect in their privacy policy and you
basically have to sign off on this
agreement before you even use their
platforms with better help on the other
hand that's not the case now I'm sure
that if you really dig deep into the
fine print somewhere it acknowledges
that they may share your data but
throughout the platform they constantly
reassure customers that privacy is a top
priority rest assured any information
provided in this questionnaire will stay
private between you and your counselor
messages with your therapist are not
shared with any third party and your
live sessions are not recorded we also
do not share when you send a message or
have a session with your therapist with
any third party this this last statement
must have been a new addition because
they used to do exactly this
back in 2020 an investigation revealed
that the better help was allegedly
sharing the metadata of therapist
conversations with Facebook Facebook was
being alerted every time a user opened
better help and sent a message this
meant that Facebook was essentially
getting a full log of when users were
having therapy sessions where they were
attending sessions from and how long
they were in sessions
when confronted about this better hope
would simply decline to answer you would
think that they would stop selling data
after this confrontation but it seems
that they may have actually just doubled
down according to an FTC report that
came out in March of 2023 betterhelp
allegedly used a wide variety of tactics
to show the health information of over 7
million consumers with Facebook Snapchat
and Pinterest they even allegedly shared
data collected from Health
questionnaires which included questions
like these are you experiencing
overwhelming sadness grief or depression
have you ever had thoughts that you
would be better off not alive and have
you taken medication or been in therapy
before why would better help share this
data you ask well so that these users
could be retargeted with better help ads
according to the FTC complaint using
this health information for advertising
betterhelp has brought in hundreds of
thousands of new users resulting in
millions of dollars in additional
Revenue this by the way seems to be
working out really well for better help
as they just had their first billion
dollar year and the fine for all of this
is just a mere 7.8 million dollars which
will be used to refund affected users as
we previously mentioned betterhelp never
admitted guilt to claiming that this was
just standard industry practice and
unfortunately they're actually right
around the same time that better help
was exposed it came out that another
online therapy platform cerebro had done
the same thing they had shared the
Private health information including
mental health assessments of 3.1 million
patients with Facebook Google and Tick
Tock and according to a report from
Mozilla it's the same case with most
other online therapy platforms as well
as such the FTC is more concerned about
reforming the entire industry as opposed
to just finding better help for as much
as possible
and in that effort they've proposed a
couple of new guidelines and reforms
the FDC has proposed a total of six new
reforms that better help must abide by
and other platforms should probably
follow as well the First Reform is
expanding the definition of health
information one of the main reasons that
these platforms are able to get away
with sharing so much information about
their users is because a lot of it like
email addresses IP addresses and
metadata isn't technically considered as
health information but the FDC is
arguing that context counts sure an
email address may not usually be
considered as health information
but when a consumer enters an email
address on a mental health platform it's
a completely different story that email
address suddenly becomes personally
identifiable information that this user
may need therapy so moving forward this
platform should treat auxiliary
information as health information as
well the second reform centers on
implementing policies practices and
procedures to protect health information
this one is pretty straightforward the
FTC claims that better help doesn't have
written policies and procedures for
protecting the privacy of health
information they also fell short on
properly training and supervising
employees that access to health
information as such platforms must
Implement more robust policies and
procedures but more importantly
platforms must get affirmative Express
consent before sharing user data with
third parties speaking of transparency
the FTC has also ruled that these
platforms must ditch their deceptive
designs one of the main reasons that
people trust these platforms so easily
is because they make statements like
this we never sell or rent any
information you share with us reading
this it's natural to think that your
private data is safe it's not until you
read the fine print that you actually
understand what's going on and the given
that no one reads the fine print almost
no one knows what's going on until
something like this report comes out
considering this the FTC has required
platforms to be more transparent about
their data collection and sharing and to
better helps credit it seems like
they're already implementing this if you
go to betterhelp's website right now
you're immediately greeted with this
Banner on the bottom that admits that
they collect and share data with meta
and Tick Tock including personally
identifiable information ideally they
wouldn't share this data to begin with
but at least now they're being
transparent about it moving on to to the
fourth performer the ftcs ordering
platforms to be more transparent about
how encryption does not necessarily
protect privacy here's the thing when
people hear that their personal data is
being encrypted they automatically
equate that to their personal data being
protected but this is a rather
misleading statement because if you give
Facebook the encrypted data along with
the keys to decrypted while the data is
still being kept secure it's not exactly
being kept private next up the fifth
reform is pretty straightforward the FTC
wants these platforms to play a more
active role in monitoring what data
their ad Partners actually collect and
share and finally the last reform
prevents platforms from misleadingly
using certain seals in their advertising
material for example betterhelp
allegedly use the term HIPAA throughout
their marketing material something that
likely conveyed that some sort of third
party or government agency had reviewed
and certified a platform when that
wasn't the case honestly all of these
reforms are great forward in making
online therapy a truly safe and private
space
but I think this still leaves one
overarching question unanswered
could we even be promoting online
therapy
foreign
why online therapy has exploded in
popularity especially with the pandemic
people like the convenience of being
able to talk to a professional from the
comfort of their homes but the simple
reality is that online therapy it
doesn't stack up to in-person therapy
and I don't think that's really a
controversial statement the in-person
connection is simply on a different
level which generally leads to far
better results but there's even more to
consider than just results one of the
biggest shortfalls of online therapy
platforms like betterhelp is that they
don't accept health insurance this means
that the entire cost of the platform and
the therapist is coming out of your
pocket the better helps credit they have
kept their pricing quite affordable All
Things Considered only 60 to 90 dollars
per week but with that being said if you
leverage your health insurance and go to
an in-person Clinic you should be able
to get a far higher quality of care for
the same out-of-pocket cost also
speaking about the quality of care
in-person clinics will almost always
have higher quality care this isn't a
knock on better helps therapists I'm
sure there's a good number of Highly
qualified therapists on betterhelp but
the key thing to note is that therapists
on betterhelp are psychologists not
psychiatrists in fact betterhelp does
not even support psychiatry interests
this might sound like a novel difference
but it's not psychiatrists are actual
medical professionals who went to
medical school and are certified to
diagnose illness and prescribe
medication psychologists on the other
hand are more or less just professionals
that you can talk to again I'm sure
there's plenty of Highly qualified
psychologists but if you need serious
help including diagnosis prescription
and professional medical advice a
psychiatrist is who you need to see
but I bet most better help users aren't
even aware of this distinction or how
better help doesn't have psychiatrists
which brings us back to the core issue
which is the commercialization of
therapy while platforms like betterhelp
may have the best of intentions they're
also trying to maximize profits in
Industries like social media search or
email it's whatever but when it comes to
mental health this becomes a lot more
dangerous
in fact most of better help Shady
activity can be attributed to their
profit motive why does better help share
personal user data with meta well to
reach as many people as possible and to
make as much money as possible why does
betterhelp have arguably misleading
promotional material well to reach as
many people as possible and to make as
much money as possible
why to better help users not know the
difference between psychologists and
psychiatrists
well because in betterhelp's pursuit of
reaching as many users as possible and
making as much money as possible talking
about services that they don't offer
isn't exactly in their best interest
so why is betterhelp dangerous well
because they're commercializing therapy
like never before and that naturally
comes along with a bunch of side effects
someone else who has sold their soul is
skillshare check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next one